everybody what's gonna you ask you clap
in the back feel free to copy everybody
no one yes we like to start out with low
energy and then we go high I'll welcome
everyone for the next 30 minutes we're
gonna be taking your questions on
YouTube and Facebook and hello to
Instagram over there in the corner
what no Instagram we are here with Jose
Arroyo Mike Sweeney Jesse Gaskell and
Conan O'Brien welcome guy Conan do you
want to explain very quickly about your
hat
what's a hat needs no explanation right
fair enough the Hat the covers his head
yes that was purchased in Sydney
Australia
yes and I wanted a hat that really said
I'm here in Australia so I got this hat
it's very Crocodile Dundee it's got the
little crocodile teeth in it and it's
got dried snakeskin and it's called
Anna kübra and say kind of had two
people and I wore it around the streets
and I looked like an nobody
wears these nobody yeah and nobody wears
these in Australia and I I thought it
was funny and I'm still not sure but I'm
sticking with it when I double down on
the things and guess what no one wears
these in Los Angeles we're taking your
questions and waffle on syrup on YouTube
ask Conan why are you whiter than the
Sun Tan Lotion we went to a place called
at the Cancer Council yeah you you you
did it up you did it up how was it
there's no ozone layer in Australia
going into Australia were you worried
about your skin very worried I have been
warned in advance that it was going to
be a different kind of climate it is
true the Australians make it very clear
that there is a hole in the ozone layer
above Australia and as I pointed out in
the special they have kind of a cheery
attitude about it
and it's very strange because you have
to really be careful there hence the Hat
and I put on the most powerful sunblock
they have in Australia which i think is
a 55 or a 60 SPF yeah I'm a giant jug it
comes from it comes in giant jugs there
and they have this slogan in Australia
slap it on sloppy but anyway I I did put
it on and yes thank you for pointing
that out waffle on syrup I I am even
whiter than the whitest cream you can
apply to my body
alright well but I will not mock your
internet handle and I'll leave that
alone waffle on Syria will tell the
river on Facebook for what it's worth
says that hat is cool AF thank you no
internet and I am the hat yeah this is
this is yeah thank you
I actually I have to say I am sticking
with this hot I love this hat and it is
now I think should be a part of every
Travel Show
I think if we go to China no I think
wherever we go this hat should be an
integral part well I am speaking the Sun
we went to Bondi Beach a very hugely
famous beach and partly famous because
of the show Bondi rescue how did that
come about you three are the the masters
of planning these trips
I think bastard all right
extreme I think it started when we were
looking for to do things with a show
that was down there and the first
thought was Shark Week doing sharks and
when that couldn't come together we
learned about bond I reckon it couldn't
come together because yeah the shark
tried to book a show yeah
the shark really yeah the shark really
was interested in meeting Ellen and
found out that oh it's that guy I'm good
we got a we got a soft pass from the
shop it was a hammerhead to get a soft
pass from a hammerhead yes was there
everyone and I did what would this shirt
what would these shark idea been well no
I what I wanted to do was actually get
Jordan they told me we have an idea for
Jordan and sharks and they didn't tell
me that they meant a dummy I was
thrilled I thought we were going to put
Jordan in a provolone speedo and lower
him into shark-infested waters and I was
the happiest I have been 25 years of
television and they were like no dummy
like a dummy what's the point of that
with that so passive-aggressive you are
you can't just fire the water with a
shark we'll do the work we did see some
wildlife though we went to the Australia
while I live walkabout part yeah which
was very cool we I remember us walking
in and I don't think any of us maybe you
guys realized but the animals were just
walking around like we walked in and a
kangaroo just hop by us
yeah maybe and it's weird because the
animals are actually I think working the
park but it was the animals are just
roaming wherever you go the animals are
just there yeah and they are fascinating
and I love the energy I have to say the
energy of the koala Gumnut and I Gumnut
really who can forget Gumnut
the just that slacker sort of millennial
energy how slowly is halarious love
Gumnut news
mesmerizing yeah yeah oh go ahead real
quick so there we wanted to pet one of
the Kangaroos a bunch of us on the crew
yeah and there was a kangaroo that had a
cute little collar on its neck and so a
bunch of us went up over to it and we
were petting it and afterwards we asked
the the Ranger oh is it okay if we pet
the Kangaroos and she said yes but just
whatever you do make sure you do not put
the one with the collar on a snag oh my
god I was the only one that we had put
the cute collar to let everybody know
that it's dangerous yeah there is there
was a lot of Australia of all the places
we have been I will say this about
Australia it's the place where the
danger lecture before is the leader is
the least merited meaning they will sit
you down and talk to you for 20 minutes
about you gotta be careful cuz it's
crazy
what's that talk of the wall how could
one back and then they going here it
comes and they pull the string and you
don't you see nothing you just see
blackness and you hear a noise and then
this incredibly erotic imagine the
oldest fattest cat you've ever seen it
has that go a day to live comes out and
looks around it's like you know I was
that they kept doing that in Australia
saying watch out watch out yeah but of
course the flip side of that is they say
and you know everybody goes to the beach
and they're rescuing people at Bondi
every five seconds because the rip
currents are so powerful there that and
and we were there in the short time we
were there I think they saved like eight
lives so and no one I mean you're an
America would shut down the beach there
they're like everyone
you know people are drowning left and
right and then they give you the big
safety lecture when you're around the
arthritic
old dying animals no lawsuits right
Kevin Newton the survival expert gave us
a huge talking to about Jack jumpers
he's tiny yeah he was scary yeah it was
it was freaky he was very scary and he
went into great detail about how we
would die yeah great detail about how
his wife crapped her pants
he was so matter-of-fact about it I've
made it more chilling yes yes when you
guys when you guys see somebody like
that are you just like yes we have to do
less because you know he's gonna be such
a character or is it a little more
challenging because in editing it's
gonna be harder to shape the piece it
depends on the personality you want
someone who will play with Conan Gavin
can play off and he was so serious about
his stuff yeah it was great for Conan to
find his moments that way somebody shows
off too much might be ya know right not
quite the best the best I mean you just
said it there's the same thing I was
thinking which is the in these travel
shows what we're finding again and again
and again enter in remote segments in
general and this is something you can
see and the room the remotes that are
online now we've got all 25 years of yep
Conan Conan on Conan 25 and the remotes
that always work the best
whether it's old-time baseball or going
to other countries and doing these
travel shows is when people are very
passionate about what they're doing and
take it very seriously
that's where comedy can bounce the
highest I think every now and then will
encounter someone who's very jokey about
what they do right and they're like oh
I'm here with the comedian so it's joke
around and if fake eyeballs yeah it it
never that's never as fun and we always
move on pretty quickly
we're there for about five minutes and
we disassembled her okay you're really
funny we're out of here we want to find
people that that are deadly serious
about what they do because that's more
compelling is much more compelling
absolutely but then we had a our soccer
manager Nick Nick Davis yes system and
really had a great sense of they are I
want to say they're one of the the
people there are naturally this is just
what we experienced naturally very very
funny quick sharp and yeah Nick when we
were shooting the footie you know the
the football what is it question
football he had he just had perfect
timing and he was someone who was a
great combination if he wasn't jokey he
was but he he he was being very honest
in assessing my body and just he was
masterful so I mean yeah Gabriela was
just great back back and forth of oh my
god that I think that's one of her best
yes yeah she was very funny
she and that's a very popular segment
yeah yeah on that segment is huge if you
haven't seen it it's the beginning of
the episode where I'm trying to learn
Australian slang and Gabrielle is I mean
first of all literally hats off to
Gabrielle because she she was just a
great improviser and funny knowledgeable
but also went went with it and and I'd
also you know very uh just very magnetic
personality yeah yes she's a star
yeah and one thing I think I've always
appreciated just as a fan that is your
employee but is you've always said
before you start a remote you explain to
the person off camera that you are the
butt of the joke you are it's let joke's
on you it's never on them and I on that
note Chloe does it on YouTube says Conan
you're courageous
for being yourself you help the younger
generation in being ourselves
and I thought nice missing nice one
thing is a great example of you just
going full I'm an ass I mean like you
were up for getting tackled you were up
for you know putting on a crazy
I think this bravest thing I did and
maybe the bravest thing I've done so far
in any travel show is where those very
short shorts my legs are are a freak
show and to to wear legs that are that
short to wear shorts that are that short
took I saw them and there was a second
of me thinking I really don't want to
put those on but I push through I put
them on and then to see those long white
stems moving around in the remote I
think brought joy to a lot of people out
there with body issues and I think
there's a lot of my comedy which is
people watching it and they can feel
like you know what I don't feel so bad
about myself I will leave the house
today I have some musculature there was
another player who tackled Conan yes he
really viciously took you down and we're
like that's going to be great we came
back three cameras all blah there was
someone spit and I get frustrated in the
moment but we do have a tip of the cap
to our crew you know they're they're
spectacular cameramen they're lifting
those giant cameras and in the moment
sometimes you'll get frustrated if they
miss they hardly ever miss anything no
but yeah of course
when I got tackled that hard and I could
feel my chest cavity collapsing I
thought at least we have the footage of
that that's love
that's going to if we have the MRI at
least we have some footage of that and
then to find out later on that oh no we
don't have that but so what just-joan on
facebook says still loving you Conan
despite the shorty shorts and Celeste on
Facebook asks what was the funniest
moment amongst the crew on the trip
besides a scene Conan get tackled and it
not making the show what was the
funniest anything springs in mind I've
got him I got a possible well I don't
know if it's the funniest but something
that really amused me is Jeff Ross our
producer we were staying in this hotel
that's right there on the water across
from the Sydney Opera House and we would
that's where we would meet up early in
the morning and have our coffee and sort
of try and wake up and say okay here's
what we got to do today and of course
what it looks out on is these giant
cruise ships a different creature every
day with the park there and if you know
if you've seen the show I'm always kind
of making fun of our producer Jeff Ross
because he's a man of few words
I sort of haven't you know doesn't say
that much he doesn't get excited about
much you know the craziest thing will
happen to be like what happened let's go
you bet wait a minute no one maybe were
a meteor just crashed and it hit and it
awoke an ancient dinosaur did you see
that you'd be like yo you know he's got
that and so he has seen everything
yeah he's unimpressed he's like saw
stuff go down in the 70s he lived he's
lived through it all and we're always
being like wow isn't that crazy but yeah
you know whatever that happens you know
no that doesn't happen
that guy just burst into flames it can
happen you know
but everyday it was really funny because
a new cruise ship would pull in into the
harbor and Jeff suddenly became a kid
yeah he was so excited about cruise
ships and what he would do is he would
look at the name of the cruise ship and
look it up so he was always up earlier
than we are yes we had come stumbling
down to get our coffee and he's there
and being hidden and hey be like guys
check it out capacity forty five
thousand whatever guess what there's a
crew of 11 hundred guess what guess what
you know it has a they eat eight hundred
hands we can get on that ship then the
next day a new cruise ship yeah guys
guys I looked it up this one was made in
Norway made in Norway looks like the
same one yesterday he was obsessed with
seeing how I was gonna back up I did he
ever see it leave he was obsessed with
he did right the missile wouldn't leave
it was so when he was obsessed with
seeing one pull out yes yes and then
depart and then he finally did and then
he told me that he didn't need to live
any longer I want to mention something
else is just a total crazy coincidence
for you this is behind-the-scenes stuff
that I find kind of fascinating and it
keeps happening and I just want to put
it out there in the universe for some
reason and I don't know why our paths
when we travel on these travel shows
keep converging with the Red Hot Chilli
soberly
when we did our Berlin Travel Show we're
in the hotel and then someone just said
I think the Chili Peppers are here and
sure enough they come in
oh hi we chat with them we you know
whatever and then we're in Australia
we're not there for that long we're it's
the first time we're there we're in
Sydney and who comes crashing through
the door but in our hotel the Red Hot
Chili Peppers Anthony Kiedis and
chatting with him and I'm thinking what
is going on and I started to ask them is
are you guys waiting to see where we're
going to decide where you're gonna
perform or is it maybe someone in our
group who's obsessed with the Chili
Peppers but I just want to see how many
more times we check into our I mean I
really do think we know that show up in
Guam and check into the Holiday Inn
there and you know what I mean flea
would be there but I think I think you
even also said that you would run into
but I think was Anthony Kiedis you know
in LA like two weeks before we're in
Australia so yeah yeah yeah it's crazy I
just I mean not and I don't see
celebrities trust me I don't see them on
my show I don't see much and some reason
I cannot they're probably gonna walk
into this room eight now because they've
got it you know it'd be great hey Jeff
it would make Jeff happy if you and the
Chili Peppers did a crucial you know we
really wanted to get Jeff a little
sailor cap I was obsessed with that's
the Hat that we needed together well
speaking of rock you did a little rock
and roll you did a live show Conan his
Australian friends with I want to make
sure we give a shout out to ya the
members of our band
well mediums yes Dean Rusk appleís Becky
Lucas and a recycle sin drug which new
person who looks like you know like
someone tried to clone me yeah and
improved upon
he's a younger sort of more spoked
adverse in the app or very bad baby they
were terrific they were three really
funny comedians and each very different
and it was a joy working with them and I
really love the way Steen opened the
show he was very creative about working
with the crowd in creating these
scenarios there's I mean obviously such
an impressive group of comedians and and
comic talent in Australia absolutely
there there really is it's just a
powerhouse I was very impressed with
them and they really helped they got the
show started and did a brilliant job and
then I came out and did some foolishness
and then it ended with a musical portion
and I want to thank the members of my
band that came along I mean that's a lot
to ask of these guys do ya all the way
to Sydney for this one date for
literally yeah Jim yeah but but Scott
Healy came and James worm Worth and Mike
came and Mike yeah Mike Merritt came and
I'm just you know so happy when I can
connect with those guys and play music
even if you know I'm holding them back a
little bit but mostly it was I was it
was really fun to - I've always been
fascinated with the vocal stylings of
ac/dc and and to try and sing that was
really was really fun that was great
yeah did it get killed and then we did a
little Skippy the bush kangaroo as well
always - I mean I give it these guys do
the worst doing smiley Frank smiling
smiling Frank smiley Frank smiley who is
has been with me since since day one and
is a really funny guy and producer on
the show but he's the one that he's
really good like a detective yes that's
what you three do it and then Frank will
also always find
this thing that we're thinking what are
you talking about it's like no no Skippy
the bush kangaroo they'll go nuts if you
bring it up and so there's a show there
yes flipper and so they they really lost
their minds when we work Skippy into it
and kind of speaking of music a little
bit more you talked to Briggs Adam
Briggs who is a member of the Yoda Yoda
Yoda Yoda nation and we did a welcome to
country smoke ceremony yeah the National
Center of indigenous excellence and that
was really cool he's a comedy writer and
you found out something cool about him
well first of all I find out that he you
know I go all the way to Australia yes
and I'm talking to someone who is part
of the indigenous community and I'm he's
an activist and I'm thinking I'm gonna
span this huge you know I'm really
interested in in spanning this giant
chasm whatever my experience and his
experience and we're gonna come together
and there couldn't be two more different
people and he worked for Matt Groening
[Laughter]
here's my Krusty the Klown back at the
Fox bungalow Anthony Kiedis
but he very talented yeah very funny and
and what was fascinating about that
segment was I mean really learning so
much about the indigenous culture that
existed in Australia long before any
settlers came and how diverse it was and
I remember he told us he was explained
to us and and they were explained to us
at the centre yeah they I think a woman
there showed me this map of Australia
and that there something like 300 and
over yeah that's three to five hundred
three to five hundred nations nations
level nation tribal nations all with
distinct languages and customs and I I
was blown away by that it was a very
interesting ceremony
yeah they were very welcoming and it was
nice to see that there's nice to see
that people are working so hard to
preserve those cultures and also make
them bring them into today that's one of
the things Briggs is doing is that it's
not you know let's let's go look through
the dusty old books and explore this
this culture yeah
he's using rap he's using animation he's
doing all of this great work and and
vital work an art that's relevant now
it's alive yeah it links yeah which I
thought yeah you know amazing yeah and
shout out to the Nampa elder uncle
Graham Graham King who died to this
amazing smoke ceremony and actually kind
of started to rain a little bit and you
know from a production perspective we
were all kind of worried like oh no but
then they said it was blood they were
like yeah absolutely yeah we fell for it
later saw a rain machine used a notebook
well half of these questions you guys
are asking is the question we always get
which is where are we going next
where are we going next we have ideas
[Laughter]
yes Denver's centrum yes Chili Peppers
man you know the just to make sure that
we we get the word out and credit goes
to where really should the there's so
much work that goes into these travel
shows before I ever get involved and so
it's the people on the couch I don't
know their names and Jason chalant me as
well yes yes yes Jason show Lemmy but
but these guys work very hard at
drilling down and and finding doing so
much legwork and we have a lot of
meetings before we
and what we really want is we want the
travel shows to look effortless and to
look just like a fun adventure but
there's so much work that goes into the
beforehand so that we are making sure
that we're only there for a week so
that's happening right now with a few
countries and we've been invited to some
countries which is always exciting and
we are going to make a decision I think
pretty soon because we have to get back
to work and do the pieces yeah we have
to get visas and I mean when you think
we have to decide by yeah all right well
before we go we just want to thank you
guys for joining us and also thank you
to Instagram somebody was asking what
your shirt says on Instagram oh this is
I just threw this on this morning this
is my third it's a third man record
shirt yeah and you know just and I think
a the rock contours are back on - oh wow
Jack wait I got a message from him the
other day and he was on a plane to I
think to Australia whoa
so I don't know if they were there now
they might be or they may have moved on
already but but if he's still there good
on you jack look out for those no one
says you know what we learned about
Australia we've been scammed all we've
been told is Fosters laughs you know
look at that you know the Sharks shrimp
on the barbie
it's prawn on the barbie and no one
drinks faster okay that's nobody and
nobody wears but look out for the shark
yeah nobody wears no well thank you guys
for joining us and thank you of course
to Jose like Jesse Conan O'Brien you can
watch it all if you haven't seen it
already team koco.com slash Australia
and who knows where we're going next
tweet ha yelling don't yell sorry we're
a small room they can hear you
at the end he gets loud and sadly so
right now we will be thank you guys for
joining us we will see you soon